Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Bonsoir,
je suis Gabriel Bender,
fils de Gérald Bender,
fils de Léonce Bender
fils de Jules Frédéric Bender,
dit Petit Jules
ou grand papa de la Barbe.
Je vis à Châtaignier,
tous ces Bender vivent à Châtaignier.
Châtaignier se trouve
dans la commune de Fully.
À Fully, selon l’office de la statistique,
les quatre plus grandes familles
sont les Carron, les Dorsaz,
les Roduits et les Bender.
Ça fait du bien d'avoir des racines.
C’est en expliquant cela à mes enfants
que je me suis rendu compte
que mon père est Bender Abbet
et ma mère Dorsaz Carron.
Donc je ne suis pas Bender,
mais Abbet Bender Carron Dorsaz.
A B C D,
C'est mon carré généalogique.
Le Centre régional d’études
des populations alpines à Sembrancher
collecte depuis une trentaine d’années,
dépouille les registres de paroisses
qui notent les naissances,
les mariages et les décès.
Ces registres ont été unifiés et en tant
que chercheur, on a accès à ces données.
Donc j’ai pu retrouver mes ancêtres
Bender, Abbet, Dorsaz et Carron,
par des clics de souris.
Je me suis rendu compte que je pouvais
remonter, je suis monté dix générations,
ce qui fait trois générations par siècle.
Et j’ai retrouvé Jean-Baptiste, François,
Pierre, Nicolas…
et j’en passe.
Donc j’étais content de retrouver
mes quatre ancêtres.
Et en faisant ça, je me suis rendu compte
que Léonce, Petit Jules, Jean-Etienne,
Jean-Etienne, Jean-Jacob, Jean-Baptiste,
c’est des hommes.
Quand on fait de la généalogie, on suit
toujours une lignée paternelle
et on oublie les femmes,
comme si les femmes
ne jouaient un rôle dans la naissance.
Donc je me suis dit qu'il fallait
trouver un autre modèle.
Et là je vous présente
mon carnet de notes,
mon carnet de sociologue, si vous voulez.
Un peu comme tout le monde, j’ai
deux parents, deux grands-parents,
4 arrières grands-parents,
8 arrières grands-parents.
Et quand je remonte ces dix générations,
en 1690, je suis tombé sur 1024 ancêtres.
Donc François Abbet, Jean-Baptiste
et les autres, Jean-André,
ne sont que quatre parmi 1020 autres.
Donc pour représenter ma généalogie,
je devrais faire 1024 arbres
généalogiques, une petite forêt.
Il y a d'autres manières de présenter ça.
Les généalogistes connaissent bien
cette méthode,
c’est de mettre Ego au centre.
Et, à partir de là, de faire rayonner.
Ainsi, les femmes sont présentes.
Alors là, vous voyez
Dorsaz, Bender, Carron…
À chaque rang, on additionne
et on découvre d’autres ancêtres.
C’est bien, j’ai vu qu’il y a beaucoup
de Grange et de Roduit.
Les plus nombreux sont les Darblay.
Cette manière de présenter
me convenait toujours pas,
je cherchais une forme graphique
qui permettrait de voir aussi
les dynamiques familiales,
les familles qui s’entendent,
qui s’accordent et tout.
Alors je me suis dit que c’était peut-être
comme ça qu’il fallait le faire.
Ou, comme je suis
quand même un scientifique,
plutôt sous forme de bibliothèque.
Je cherchais cette forme graphique
et aucune me satisfaisait
car on peut faire autre chose
avec des données généalogiques.
Je rappelle : naissances, mariages, décès,
une date, un lieu, des témoins.
Et je me suis dit que les grandes absentes
des histoires familiales,
c’est les grands-mères,
voire les grands-mères des grands-mères.
Je me suis dit, peut-être que je vais
retrouver ces grand-mères.
Et je les ai trouvées.
Et forcément, il y en a huit.
Elles s’appellent
Angélique Terreta, à Vens,
Geneviève Pellot, à Chemin,
Véronique Grange à Buitone,
Euphrosine Carron à Eulau,
Marie Euphrosine Carron à Planuy,
Julie Roduit et Virginie Roduit,
à Randone.
J’étais très surpris parce moi qui pensais
être un Bender de la plaine, à Chataigner,
je retrouve ces ancêtres,
elles sont toutes à la montagne,
dans des micro villages,
le plus grand village, c’est Buitone.
Que pourrait-on faire
avec le registre ?
Plutôt que faire toujours
de la généalogie verticale,
si on faisait la généalogie horizontale ?
Qui vivait en même temps
que cette Angélique à Vens ?
Et je me suis amusé à chercher,
j’ai trouvé toutes les personnes
de sa génération
qui étaient nées comme elle
entre 1801 et 1820 à Vens.
Et au-dessus de Sembrancher.
Et j’ai vu qu’un tiers d’habitants
étaient des Terreta, par exemple.
On peut représenter comme ça
le village d’Angélique.
Je sais pas
si c’est géographiquement juste,
toutes les maisons ont la même taille.
Là, je me suis dit
qu’on pouvait aussi représenter
toutes les naissances
pendant un temps donné
et ici, c’est toutes les naissances
à Chemin de 1750 à l’an 2000.
Qu’est-ce qu’on observe ?
On voit que des familles sont remplacées :
D’abord il y avait des Auber,
des Berguerand, puis d’un coup,
il y a des Pellots qui arrivent en 1830
puis disparaissent.
On va trouver des dynamiques,
des villages qui se remplissent,
se vident, se transforment.
De nouvelles personnes
arrivent dans les villages.
On pourrait aussi représenter le village
dans des maisonnées,
grâce aux recensements de population
pour connaître
la population exacte à un moment donné.
Tout à coup, ces lignes, ces données,
qui n’étaient que des centaines
de milliers de lignes
dans des fichiers Excel,
des pixels sur l’écran.
Ces personnes sont nées quelque part,
elles sont mortes quelque part,
elles ont vécu, ont donné la vie
puisqu’elles sont toutes grand-mère.
J’aimerais les représenter
avec de la couleur,
les représenter en leur donnant un visage,
parce qu’elles ont été oubliées de tous,
et même des cimetierres.
Alors, si on veut faire un village,
on peut représenter
l’entier d’une commune,
les 800 habitants de la commune de Fully,
répartis dans chaque village,
car les curés notaient
de manière très précise
les naissances, le village, le hameau,
le maire, voire l’alpage.
Donc on savait précisément
où les gens étaient nés.
Et par exemple, je vois qu’à Randonnat,
il y avait 88 Roduit
et pas de produits à Branson.
Alors on pourrait faire l'inverse.
Zoomer sur une maison
et suivre une maison.
Par exemple, la maison de droite.
Elle passe toujours de père en fils.
Donc c’est les mêmes qui sont là
du début jusqu’à la fin,
tandis que la maison de gauche,
de manière assez irrégulière,
Un père…
C’est la fille qui hérite.
Lorsque la fille hérite d’une maison,
il doit chercher un époux
ailleurs dans le village,
puisqu’il y a juste deux maisons.
Donc je me suis intéressé
à la circulation des épouses.
Et par exemple, ici à Randonnat,
je me suis aperçu que de 1660 à 1837,
tous les mariages étaient célébrés
entre Roduit
et une femme extérieure de la commune.
Jusqu’à ce que mon ancêtre,
Julie Marie Roduit Dorsaz…
Et puis c’est un peu la catastrophe.
Il y a des Gay, des Gay, …
Et peu à peu,
les Roduit quittent le village,
s’installe dans la plaine du Rhône
et laissent la place à des migrants.
qui viennent de Savoie ou d’Entremont.
(Rires)
Cette migration est aussi montrée
par les naissances :
toutes les naissances à Randonnat
de 1670 à 1920.
Là aussi, vous voyez tous les enfants
comme les parents sont Roduit
Puis tout à coup, vous voyez, il y a mon
ancêtre qui a marié un Dorsaz,
À peu près à la fin, uand vous regardez,
il n’y a plus que des Dorsaz.
Mais on peut aussi voir quels sont
les prénoms à la mode :
Zénobie, Barbe, Marie-Égyptienne.
Il y avait des très beaux noms,
Euphrosine,
qui étaient très beaux et qui ont disparu.
Alors c’est très compliqué
quant à la généalogie :
par exemple il y avait
treize Jean Symphorien Roduit
en même temps dans la commune,
il faut les replacer.
J’ai réussi à savoir chacun,
j’ai replacé, sauf le petit de droite.
Il avait quatorze ans,
on ne sait pas qui il est.
Je me suis aperçu aussi qu’il y avait
des clans dans les villages :
à Tassonières, Angélique Coture, 77 ans,
elle est parent
à tous les habitants du village.
Soit tante, soit mère,
soit belle-mère, soit grand-tante.
Donc c'est la tante à Véronique,
mon ancêtre.
J’ai remarqué aussi qu’il y avait…
On parle souvent de mortalité infantile,
mais il y avait au contraire
des familles nonagénaires.
Par exemple, les enfants
de Virginie Roduit
et de Marie Daria Bender
ses…
six frères et demi-frères isolés,
ils totalisent 500 ans à six.
83 ans en moyenne et deux personnes
qui arrivent à 95 ans.
Je découvre aussi qu'il y a des fratries
énormes à cause des remariages.
Par exemple, Célestine,
l’aînée de la famille, est né en 1853,
et puis la dernière,
elle est morte en 2000.
La même famille, la même fratrie,
dans le jeu des demi-frères
et des demi-sœurs.
Je découvre aussi que Julie Roduit
était bien pressée de marier son fils
puisqu’il s’est marié à seize ans
avec une fille qui en avait treize.
Ils étaient douze chez le notaire
pour signer l'acte.
Il faut dire que la Véronique Raclot,
elle était orpheline
et elle avait des biens
Je vois aussi par exemple à Buitone,
dans la famille de Mélanie Binder,
ils marient soit des gens de Mazinbrau,
ou de Lettron,
mais jamais des gens de Eulau ou Planuy,
c’est des Bagnard, des Carron,
c’est des pauvres.
Je découvre qu’au même moment,
dans le même village,
mon fils aurait pu rencontrer
quelqu’un qui lui dit :
« Son père, c’est le père du père,
du père de ton père. »
Six génération entre les deux,
je comprends un peu mieux
les vieilles rognes politiques,
la mémoire familiale, bien entendu,
si le gars a des souvenirs de son père
qui était né 156 ans plus tôt.
Je découvre aussi des destins étonnants.
Par exemple, ce monsieur,
Jean-Pierre Joseph Bonde.
Il a eu dix enfants, six femmes,
trois mariages.
Si on n’avait pas mis les registres,
si j’avais pas réuni les registres,
comme les enfants sont chaque fois
dans des paroisses différentes,
on ne savait pas
qu’il avait eu dix enfants.
Six femmes, trois mariages,
il y a souvent des enfants illégitimes.
On trouve des aventures, alors après,
j’ai commencé à donner des visages,
puis finalement, je me suis lancé
dans la bande dessinée.
Et là, par exemple, c’est une histoire
incroyable d’une fiancée,
elle est née en Savoie.
Elle a vécu, à Fully.
Elle est partie au Brésil, au Parana.
Elle a perdu un enfant en route.
Elle a perdu son mari au Brésil,
elle était enceinte.
Elle est rentrée du Brésil
avec son enfant.
Elle s’est remariée et à Fully.
Elle est repartie vivre en Algérie.
Elle a de nouveau fait
un enfant en Algérie.
Elle a perdu son mari en Algérie.
Elle est revenue avec un enfant illégitime
et elle s’est installée à Fully.
Et sur son registre, il y a marqué :
Née à Fully, morte à Fully.
(Rires)
Je voulais remercier Euphrosine,
Véronique, Virginie, Angélique, Julie,
Geneviève, Mélanie et les autres qui m’ont
permis de vous donner cette conférence
et de faire en partie
ce que je suis, où j’en suis.